hey guys today it is the sixth of July
my name is Jess McDonald and he is a
bunch of knees in these the probably
won't surprise any of you pewdiepie is
so much richer than the rest of us the
news part of this story is that
financial documents have indicated just
how much richer he is than the average
Joe PewDiePie or Felix Kjellberg earned
the equivalent of 7.5 million bucks last
a year according to Swedish newspaper
Expressen as translated by neoga
PewDiePie productions ad is now making
63 million Swedish kerna a year that's
up from 29 points 6 million in 2013 and
7.2 million in 2012 PewDiePie has been
running his channel for six years has 37
million subscribers and generates over 4
million bucks in ad sales per year
anyone who's played Skyrim can tell you
that it is riddled with bugs although
Bethesda have said that all that is
contributing to making fallout 4 better
pull out for game director todd howard
told game informer that the release of
skyrim and it's dlc has taught the
company how to deal with bugs and issues
in future howard said that they also
learned what issues to prioritize should
similar bugs arise explaining for us the
players thanked game is the number one
thing if the game crashes that's bad but
it's nowhere near as bad as someone
saved being hosed that's our scenario
that we will do anything and everything
to avoid he added all of the updates we
did on Skyrim and all of the DLC once we
sort of the bugs out we had a different
process for how we checked the content
out fallout 3 and new vegas were also
notoriously buggy games finally a new
ps4 model has popped up in japan and
it's super nice on the inside according
to an analysis by pocket news the
analysis which has been translated and
reported by Eurogamer details model see
you h 1200 currently only available in
japan the new model features a smaller
motherboard with a new gddr5 memory can
duration featuring half the memory
modules of the previous ps4 models on
the whole making the console more
energy-efficient other changes include a
new blu-ray drive design a new hdmi
controller a new power supply which is
80 grams lighter than the previous one
with a lower energy output and a new
designation for the main processor it's
also been suggested that Sony has
reduced the noise of the PS Wars fan
while the chassis has the same form
factor the hard drive cover reportedly
has a matte finish instead of the usual
glossy one let me know down in the
comments what your strangest Skyrim or
fallout bug a moment has been you can
head to gain spot we've got news on a
car manufacturer getting fooled by video
game graphics and a spiritual successor
to make a man legend that is everything
I have for you today let me know down in
the comments what you cared about and
i'll catch you same time tomorrow